je suis allé avec mon petit tu chamarré
tourner les frères dans les rues de
paris
qu'est ce qui se passe avec les braves
ancien club et ça me fait peur mais il
faisait un peu froid et sec et froid
mais on a fait quand même on va dans la
rue on demande aux gens ce qu'ils
pensent des transports en commun
parisiens
et pendant ce temps on s'habille à peu
près comme eux c'est pas qui ça remet
enfin qu'est ce que vous pensez de
transports en commun parisiens les
transports parisiens sont vraiment très
efficace leur réseau est vraiment très
ténus et c'est vraiment super de prendre
le métro le bus à paris et votre seul en
pense quoi
je n'ai pas de soeur première nouvelle
regardez du vrai du faux
lardé ça c'est tout pourri ça 19 nov
voilà et tué une heure tu l'as toujours
la presse n'avait qu'à être là préfèrent
préféré mais c'est ça qu'est ce que vous
pensez les transports en commun de paris
et les transports sont plutôt bien fait
notamment de métro ça c'est unique au
monde il ya plein de sensations que ces
pratiques
maintenant c'est vrai que ça fonctionne
pas toujours très bien donc il faut
faire attention se renseigner et votre
elle en pense quoi
je sais pas comment ça va
mariage à côté d une ambiance de fou les
malgaches y va non non mais fâché je
vois plus mon frère est super obligé de
faire ça aurait fait ressembler de
seconde à la télé tu vois c'est pas chez
pourquoi à 10h de famille sous droits
d'auteur était pour moi aux potes berry
tâche et signe en californie journal
foot pour moi ça compte pas ses mots en
français qui comptent comme on réglera
ça plus tard hier auprès rouge
trouve pas très propres après c'est
pratique c'est rapide
voilà c'est un bon transporteurs et
votre chat l'on pense quoi ma soeur
alors dans ce coin n'a pas fait de toi
un poilu j'appelle tampa bay temps de
faire mon footing et encore tu voyais en
bas c'est non
l'amazonie tous ces mots sifel amazon
les gens riches et mère tu attends le
petit a donné les nouvelles données
nouvelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]